some people have noticed for the
comments in some of the latest computer
file videos that there's a new option
for viewing them instead of just being
1080p and 720p you've now got 1080p50
what on earth is 1080p 50 the number
after the P refers to the frame rate how
many different frames per second are
there in the video sequence that you see
now before because we shoot in the UK
Sean will be shooting most of the time
at 25 frames per second so yeah so my
hand isn't running at 25 frames per
second and you'll see it sort of jerks a
bit compared to my face which is
speaking at 50 frames per second let's
back up a second actually what what do
we mean when we talk about frame rates
or frames per second well when things
move when I drop this pen for example
it's a continuous motion it starts off
here and it falls through all the
positions in space until it hits the
table and stops now when we capture that
to display on video on film we don't
capture all the motion what we do is we
sample it just like your sample audio
into lots of discrete segments if you
actually look at a piece of film you can
start to see this quite easily what
there here's a piece of 16 mil film you
can see that actually you've got lots
and lots of individual images and each
of those images we refer to as a single
frame and when you project you this fear
we literally shine a light through that
I hope you projected onto the screen and
then a bit later when we move it up show
the next one and so on and so by doing
that fast enough you get the appearance
of motion projected either on your
computer screen or at the cinema I mean
we're used to thinking about an image as
being a two-dimensional thing when we're
making that into video we're also
extending that effectively into another
dimension time and so at the beginning
we have this image at time zero so this
is time along here and then it's some
other point that's per there's no point
five seconds of course in the real world
you've got XY and z directions on the
computer screen it's flat so we forget
about the Zed and then you have XY and
of course we have time as things move
about around it so that Y here and X
here
and we can talk about these things at
being in different positions at
different time so at t zero this thing
here is a bit off the bottom and a half
way across at t nor point five it may be
that the left-hand edge of the image so
it's changing position now you could
describe how that moves you can say i
want to move this from here to here the
computer could draw all the movements
actually when we shoot something with
video or film we do something different
we break it up into discrete samples
just like when you make digital audio
you take the waveform and break that up
into discrete samples we do the same
with video so we break the video up like
this so we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 different frames for that half a
second and each of those frames just
represents the image at that point in
time so at point zero we take it a photo
and we've got this one are then at time
no point 5 over 12 which would be naught
point naught 4 we take another photo and
then at no point naught 8 we take
another photo and so on so our frame
rate the number of frames per second is
just literally how many times are we
going to divide this block up per second
so in this case in half a second block
we've got 12 different gaps so this
would be recording at 24 frames per
second and that is the standard frame
rate that's used for movies
interestingly the reason they went for
24 frames per second is all to do with
money when they introduce a sound into
the cinemas they needed to increase the
frame work from what they're using in
the past which is about 16 or 17 for
something like some of the early silent
movies to something where they could
actually record the audio and get the
decent quality of sound and 24 frames
per seconds was the cheapest frame rate
basically that could get away with so
they use less film so it cost less to
shoot something but they all still had
decent quality sound completely
arbitrary decision and actually if you
look at all the frame rates used in TV
and video things they've all been made
for similar reasons so for film it was
reducing the amount of film I had to
shoot of TV it was down to the frequency
of the mains system but we'll come back
to that later
what's the ideal frame rate
the best one to use is that if this
wasn't down to cost what's the best
friend infinity if you use an infinite
framerate your samples it'd all be zero
width therefore you've captured every
single bit of motion actually the best
framerate is a difficult question to ask
because it's since highly related to
what you're trying to capture if you
think to audio you need a sample rate
which is twice the maximum frequency you
want to catch due to Nyquist and
Shannon's laws so you have around 48
kilohertz is what's generally used for
audio because it's well over twice the
frequency you can hear about 20
kilohertz 24 frames per second was
chosen for cinema because it's generally
good enough for capturing the motion
it's only when you get things going
quite fast from rotating that you
actually see it the classic example is
you sometimes see in films car wheels
and things or things like that that's
spinning you'll suddenly see them start
to go the opposite direction then as
they get bit faster they'll start going
the right direction again this might
sound like a silly question for me
because I'm the one who's chosen to
shoot at 50 feet but if 24 is adequate
to capture motion and I've been shooting
at 25 which is even more frames per
second
why does 50 look so different right was
actually so this is the interesting
thing is actually if you were to look at
the frames captured at 25 P and captured
at 50 P side by side for the same time
for most things they would look or might
sit identical the problem isn't with the
capture so we can ignore capturing it
now because that's pretty much the same
whatever frame way we do the problem
comes to when we try and display it
particularly when you try and display it
in a cinema if you think about a piece
of film so they're all these individual
frames and the way a classic film
projector works is you have a light
behind it but the problem comes I want
to display the next frame in that we
have to move the film up mechanically so
the next frame is in front of the light
and projector through the lens onto the
screen now you've got mechanical
properties here you have to move into an
exact position so you've got a core
mechanism with just that but you can't
still be transmitting the light to the
screen otherwise you'd get the blur as
the film moved up and it would just look
like a blurring mess as it went and was
you actually have to physically display
the whole image and the way that it does
that is there's a spin
disk which covers the frame-up so you
get a bit of black between on the screen
and then you get the next one and so
you've got image then black then image
then black that image then black turns
out if you do that around 24 frames per
second it looks horrible it flickers
like mad your brain can still see the
flickering on the screen and you don't
see the motion you start to see it as a
set of separate images so the way we got
around this when they did build the
first film projectors is that rather
than displaying each frame once they
displayed each frame try so you show
frame one covering black show frame one
again give it a black move it up to be
frame two showing frame two covered with
black so frame two so you're actually
showing 48 frames per second but you've
actually only got 24 discreet frames
you're just showing each of them twice
now what happens is the brain sometimes
looks at that and thinks what on earth
is going on and I've got a demonstration
over on the computer here so I'm going
to play this back you will suddenly see
that it appears to be two circles even
though on every frame there's only ever
one circle on-screen so if I set this
playing you will see you get the
appearance as it moves across as if
there's two circles sort of overlaid on
top of each other and so one of the
things that gives film its look is that
you have these two frames laid on top of
each other so the projectors show thing
the frame twice or even three times on
some projectors to get around the
flicker problem and because of the
mechanical nature of them now a
television works in a slightly different
way in television particularly a CRT
like the monitors behind me are a single
dot which is flying across the screen
from left to right across the screen and
moving down so it's only ever a tiny
single dot every other minute at a time
but it scans from the top left through
to the bottom right and it sort of
zigzag pattern every 50th of a second so
it appears to display whole image if you
slow it down you can actually see the
image being built up on the display now
they have the same problem if they just
had the CRT display at 24 frames per
second or 25 frames per second then
would look horrible you'd see the
flicker so they displayed them at 50
fields per second and the reason they
chose 50 or 60 is to deal with the
frequency of the mains in the UK and the
US and in different countries in the UK
the mains frequency works at 50 Hertz
and by choosing your frame rate that
matches that you remove a possibility of
getting interference on-screen or rather
you remove the possibility of the
interference being visible on screen so
it's a technical consideration again
that made 50 in the UK or 60 in the u.s.
a good choice for the frame rates so
they update the image on the screen
every 50th of a second of course because
it's all electronic and not having to
move physical pieces of film you can now
capture each of those things 50 times a
second and so actually we have a higher
motion rate and because we're not
showing everything twice if we come back
to the demonstration what I've got is
two videos now this one is the same one
we had before this time is at 30 frames
a second two of them 24 and this one is
at 60 frames per second what we see if
we've run both of these is that this one
strobe still although it's slightly less
because it's at 30 frames we got double
imaging but this one is much smoother
because we've got the same images
sampled a lot of thing and the brain
isn't having to work out and I'm seeing
this image twice or what's the motion
doing it's only seeing each image once
and so it looks right this is why film
still looks like film when it's shown on
the television the film is shot at 24
frames a second and each of those frames
is shown twice or three times to get the
frame rate up to 50 or 60 times per
second when it's placed a still get that
double imaging which is what gives film
is look not the fastest 24 frames a
second it's a bribe it's a nice fret of
the fact that things are shown twice why
don't we go to 50 frames per second
things don't look like so yes I mean
when we get to shooting at 50 frames per
second or 60 frames per seconds or even
higher things look the things stop
looking like film and look more real
because the motion rendition as we saw
on the demonstration is more realistic
you're seeing each frame once and so
your brain is able to work out saying oh
that's the circle moving from left
rather than thinking hang on what on
earth's going on here with this motion
and so on it can actually understand the
motion because it's similar to what it
sees in everyday life and if you
increase it to say 100 120 or even up to
300 it would be even more like and you'd
have even more realistic looking video
the problem comes if you then try and
display that image directly on screen
because things are moving between each
of those things you get these sort of
little zigzag effects because actually
this letter T here is moving
horizontally so each time it's captured
the lines at a different point